malgré un temps capricieux la quatrième
édition du salon saveurs et jardins
organisée par l'association la voix de
gambe et se tenait au château de
neuville habituellement fermés au public
en dehors des journées du patrimoine
qu'on essaye de faire c'est de faire
quelque chose qui touche au niveau du
jardin étant vestimentaire parce que
vous allez pouvoir voir un chapelier
enfin une personne qui vont des chapeaux
on essaye de toucher un petit peu le
jardin par toutes ses formes et après il
ya la gastronomie une soixantaine
d'exposants étaient présents avec
notamment des producteurs locaux sur mon
ce temps je propose la vente de viande
charolaise qui est conditionnée sous
vide
alors aujourd'hui je ferai de la viande
direct individuellement enfin petit
paquet un peu plus loin située dans la
vallée de la vaucouleurs la pisciculture
de ville est installé depuis 1896 autour
d'un moulin à eau
participez également au salon alors ce
qu'on propose
ce sont des rillettes et des terrines de
poisson à base de saumon fumé et de
truite fumée
vous avez également à
du saumon fumé qui vient des cosses
transformer chez nous donc on le salon
le fume et je les tranchées à la
gastronomie produits du jardin
conférence 1800 passants ont déambulé
tout le week-end dans les allées du
salon saveurs et jardins qu'on habite à
la campagne pour nous c'est l'occasion
d'allier la proximité de tous les
commerçants de la région de pouvoir
allier aussi à la fois la gastronomie et
puis tout ce qui est fleurs et potagers
et en fait c'est nos centres d'intérêts
puisque c'est surtout l'occasion de
faire une sortie en famille le prochain
rendez vous est fixé l'année prochaine
toujours au château de neuville le
dernier week-end d'avril avec tous le
même souhait une météo plus clémente